well saturday will mark 20 years since 9
11. and this week the i-team is bringing
you stories a southern nevada remembers
that fateful day vanessa murphy is here
with the story of one las vegas local
who was on the front lines vanessa
denise frank pizarro dealt with the
grief of losing fellow firefighters on 9
11. he also was part of the recovery
effort to find their bodies the pain and
trauma he lives with every day
i remember myself telling the chief
you know a lot of guys going to die
today
frank pizarro remembers the ride from
his new york city firehouse to the world
trade center on september 11 2001 where
destruction continued because there was
a verizon building that was a block over
and we had gone into search after the
first two towers have come down
and five minutes after we got out of
that that thing came down in the days
and months that followed we went digging
through the pile
hoping to find anything or anybody he
was part of search efforts it was
powerful because
we would find say a fireman from a
specific house
and all work would stop and we would
call that firehouse
so they could come and bring him out of
the hole and so it was it was a sight to
be seen the aisle would line up and
everybody would stand attention and
salute as he would be carried out
and this happened over and over and over
again 20 years later he remains proud to
wear the uniform i would do it all over
again you know it's it's probably the
best job in the world
and
i lost a lot of friends
and brothers and
that i'll never forget he retired in
2017 and then moved to las vegas like
many first responders at ground zero he
says he has health issues including lung
disease but that doesn't keep him from
his passion i decided that i'm going to
sing until i can't sing anymore
it's not as easy as it used to be
but i give everything i got
and i'm going to sing until the last
note comes out
from 9 11 tributes in southern nevada to
the world series in new york pizarro
continues to share his voice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and pizarro is going to sing at a
fundraiser on 9 11 here in las vegas he
also started a charity to help remember
fallen firefighters we have information
on both at 8newsnow.com